هل هناك سماع لدوي انفجار كبير
ربما قبل قليل سيد احمد
يعني سمع لي ربما دوري انفجار
سيد النور اذا سمحت قبل قليل كان هناك دوي
انفجار ربما ضخم
امامنا في الصوره ايضا تبدو
الدخان ايضا في الصور المباشره التي
تابعناها قبل قليل هذه الصور من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم نحاول يعني التاكد من
الموقع يعني تحديدا اذا هو في محيط نعم
مقر القياده العامه بالعاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم اذا دوي انفجارات كبيره في محيط
مقر القياده العامه بالخرطوم كنا قد
تابعنا قبل قليل الجيش
السوداني نشر فيديو بالقرب او من داخل
طبعا مقر القياده العامه من امام يعني
البوابه بوابه القياده العامه
بالعاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم القياده
العامه للق المسلحه طبعا كما ذكرنا ذوي
انفجارات كبيره وانفجار ضخم قبل قليل
تابعنا واياكم على الهوائي مباشره
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات